hi I'm Jimmy Vivino here with the music
minute backstage at Conan with Ziggy
Marley
[Music]
proud to have you here ma'am thank you
friend for spending the time I know
you're very busy this is just out yeah
it's great thank you for putting it out
I thought I knew a lot about Bob Marley
and the Wailers and it turns out there's
a lot more what was the first music you
heard I mean what's the first music your
first music hearing was weird as music
yes yeah from being at home and and
going to the studio with that stuff the
early early yeah yeah when did you know
that you wanted to play music the music
was just I'm like worried it just really
like breathing yeah this is a part of a
life it's not like sorry no yeah it's
just it's integrated into everything
else you know it just not sure I
followed your your brother David and one
of the people that I think a very
talented family it seems like all of the
brothers and sisters get together
because I'm a father I'm a mother we
thought about my mother she was
accepting are all kids you know it
doesn't matter if it's hers are not very
open very open about you know loving
each other as brothers and sisters
nothing can divide us no matter you know
a different mother what it did no
division between us as well one father
basically and that keep us together well
the original tribes of Israel operated
the same way it was a patriarch and a
lot of children I know what we do is
comes from some of that will Testament
all testifies and ideas in this movie
there's so much I can't even tell you
how your mother is
it's just so she was so responsible for
a lot of the success continues yeah yeah
I mean she was a rock
she was the constant thing that was
always there no matter what was
happening around she took a bullet in
the head yeah because of this you know
still stood up beside him at the concert
after I mean she could have been like
you know I have a bullet in my head I
need to go lie down in a hospital and
she she had a bullet in her head and
still showed up so she she was what type
of a woman she was on what type of
relationship she and my father kind of
had it was like oh you know I'm saying
it was beyond what everyone else can
imagine that
exactly the music your father made in
the music you're making now is a very
personal music it's not like oh let's go
out and do and sing 10 Bob Marley songs
like it's so personal to sing that I
think you as family singing it but it's
like religious music in a way and when
you listen to it it's the spiritual sure
that you I was talking to scratch Lee
Perry
yeah-hoo-hoo again I've known from only
as a as a little boy father taking me to
his studio he was a he was a produce an
innovator in in reggae music and we were
talking about the music like what was
happening today in the music and he was
telling me you know there's a magic
that's missing from today a music that
they used to have and that's that
spiritual thing in the music that is a
magic in what my father does and a lot
of the artists from his time when they
were making the music in the studios it
wasn't just plain it was like a tribal
kind of metaphysical right it was a
whole thing because his music is not
just about musing about the world
culture yes I style yeah you know that's
what it's really about well this makes
us aware too of a you know people who
don't know about Rastafari about how do
Selassie it without the religion and the
smoking and the music is obviously
gospel music yeah yeah check the movie
out people it's it's out now producer I
think along with Rita and bunny and and
the director or Kevin Macdonald great
job
yes if you think you know you don't get
this yeah and thank you so much
[Music]